So in suite number 15, based on everything we just learned previously, we said that when it comes to going to a restaurant where an irreligious Jewish waiter will be the one to open the bottle of wine and possibly even pouring the wine or shaking the wine, so we said the best thing is to avoid it and don't rely on all the leniencies that we said before because it's avoidable.
however if it's unavoidable and the waiter will be offended to tell him that he's not allowed to
open your bottle so then we said there are there is grounds to allow it if a irreligious parent
would recite Kiddush drink from the cup and then offer the wine to their religious child again the
best thing would be is to avoid drinking it if it's impossible there are there is ground to
be lenient to drink it as well okay now when we discuss the concept of Nitzuk so Nitzuk is the
The definition of Nitzok is when kosher wine is poured into a cup or a container which contains non-kosher wine
and the stream that is going between the bottle which is pouring into the container or the cup is completely unbroken.
It is an unbroken stream.
In this scenario, we view it as if the wine which is inside the cup or the container is now inside of the bottle which was being poured from into
and potentially can forbid the bottle itself that is being poured out of now the question is what kind
of what type of wine are we talking about that's inside of the cup so first of all the the wine
whatever it is it must be wet enough that it would be uh it's wide enough to get your hand wet which
could then wet something else and also when we say that it's non-kosher wine so the Shach told us that
has to be that it's wine which is forbidden both from drinking and from benefit if it's only
The Rama does say that Nitzuk would apply to wine which is touched by a Christian.
If the wine in the cup would only be prohibited from being in contact with a Muslim or an irreligious Jew though,
so then Nitzuk does not apply because it is certainly permitted to benefit from that wine
and therefore Nitzuk does not apply to that scenario.
In a case of great loss of money where the bottle that was being poured from was very expensive,
so then the Shulchan Aruch said that we would allow the bottle that was poured from, we would not apply Nitzuk.
The Rama did qualify those by saying there has to be a case of significant loss.
If it's just a small amount of wine or it's inexpensive wine, so then we would apply Nitzuk and we would forbid the bottle that was poured from.
We also mentioned another leniency from the Rama, that the Rama said we can use the concept of bitul peshishim in the context of Nitzuk.
So again, so we view as if the contents of the cup that are being poured into are now inside the bottle that is being poured from.
bitul b'shishim
We're relying on the fact that the bottle will be 60 times the wine that's inside the cup.
That would be Mevat Ezzel Chachila, which we say is prohibited.
If let's say a person was pouring kosher Mevushal wine into a cup which is containing forbidden wine,
it still could become prohibited.
The Mevushal wine can become prohibited because although it's Mevushal and protected from being touched by a non-Jew,
again, because Nitzuk is viewed as if the wine in the cup is being mixed with the wine in the bottle,
then being Mavushel would not protect it
if a non-Jew would ever pour wine to dispose of it
they're pouring it down the drain
so then the wine would be permitted
that's not subject to the rules of Stam Yeinam
also if a non-Jew would touch wine with the sole intent of making it forbidden to Jews
they were really trying to make the Jews upset and ask for their wine
so then it would be permitted
and it should even be drunk in front of them
to show them that they were not successful
We then introduced the topic of leaving wine unattended with non-Jews.
So there are two real concerns when leaving wine unsupervised with a non-Jew.
First of all, we are concerned that the non-Jew may touch the wine with the intent to libate and therefore can prohibit the wine that way.
Also, we are concerned that perhaps the non-Jew exchanged the kosher wine with forbidden wine, and now the wine inside of the bottle is actually prohibited.
Regarding this second concern that the non-Jew had exchanged the wine, so there has to be, this does take some time for the non-Jew to go get forbidden wine and then to make that exchange, and therefore we assume it would take a little bit longer than a mil for him to do that, in which case, again, we would not allow wine to be left with a non-Jew, especially not for a time that's longer than a mil.
However, if let's say a person did leave an open bottle of wine with a non-Jew, unintended.
So in a case where the non-Jew was a Christian or a bona fide idol worshiper,
so then the Shulchan Aruch says that the wine is forbidden, even if you just left for a few seconds.
Again, the concern is that the Christian or idol worshiper had touched the bottle of wine
and made it forbidden because he had intent to libate.
The Rama did say that because Christians nowadays have the status of Muslims and are non-idol worshippers, he does not go as far as Shulchan Aruch, and he would not prohibit the wine immediately, it would take much longer.
But in a situation where the wine was left with a Christian, according to the Rama, or even according to Shulchan Aruch, if it was left with a Muslim, or an irreligious Jew, or any other non-idol worshipping individual, so if it's in the home of a Jew, and there's no other non-kosher wine around, so the concern is that maybe they switched it with non-kosher wine.
In which case, it would only be prohibited if it was left with them for the time that it takes to walk a mill, which is more than 18 minutes or more than 24 minutes, but anything less than that, we would not be concerned that they had swapped out the wine.
If there is a concern that the non-Jew may drink from the wine or make direct contact with it for their own benefit,
so then again the wine becomes forbidden immediately, assuming that they are someone who would cause the wine to be prohibited if they would come in direct contact with it.